disclaimer nothing that you're about to
see in the following video has been
directly copy from her at one or Jerry
cuba's video but some parts to mimic his
personality and really to this video
stuff this video is for exact
representation taken as a joke this is
just for fun so please understand that
your discretion is advised thank you
hey guys what's up is h j cooper and
today we're going to see how good its
aerobics very cute it's not the best
proportion here is conserve a segway for
beginners who have a crappy rebel expand
you and so doing it better cute but they
don't want to spend money on one because
their mother to your kidney let's
find out I usually tell beginners to
just spend a few extra bucks and get any
longer but this cube just might have a
purpose everybody has a ram rubik ran
through but they just lying around so
why not put to Bennigan's and by no
means am I telling you to go buy a rip
expand 3 by 3 for 13 bucks which is five
bucks for the night ghoul on which is a
100 times better and do i'm about to do
this is focused more for beginners who
just happen to have a robust man 3 by 3
lying around and they have nothing
better to use and before we continue I
just wanna show you guys that this is
actually uh terbush brand you like you
can see that it is really for in Cuba so
going back to the cube the cube was much
nicer than today but it does have a lot
of catching that wouldn't matter much
because a cute beginner wouldn't be
going too fast it does have a silky and
butter it feel to it which I do not very
blocky and it's feel is best described
by ulam it's very loud and crunchy and
stability as well okay that's a big
improvement over no more with expand to
corner cutting is not the best as you
would expect its max moved one cube II
forward and reverse is not even though
it's barely anything it's like don't
beat the view
the biggest issue I've had with this
cube has got to be the locking there's
just so many levels I probably have a
lock up every four weeks also there's a
lot of public since aerobics webcam
doesn't have our public mechanism it
pops very very frequently and a car just
drink it's nothing bad about audience
simply it's important to us pretty often
even though there are so many issues
with this cute I don't think it will
affect the printer and watch I'm pulse
will have a much faster cube I think
he'll prefer even with these drawbacks
let's take a look and into your pieces
take a look at hp's right now there are
good okay so I set out although these
parts right here all four and the sport
the sport and the sport I said I'm
select just less space will take this
and this so that there's more room for
this boot and then on the edge piece on
corner piece in you just on this part
this part and this part and these three
works so there's more room again so
that's what I did with the corners and
edges that's on the time you look
all I did to improve its significantly
was foreign money sadly sorry about that
I was if I made a whole way too big and
you can see trust leading to uncountable
number of tourists and then I just
filled it with Sebastian reason I moved
it vastly just because beginners don't
have real herbs such as Maru aluminum
but everyone has fastened just lying
around then I sticker that goes all
stickers are about 50 years old and burn
very good golly I just broke it in I
thought that is what it is it fits a
longish looking at the Boston
nevertheless foolish will probably get
sucked in with this cube and so it's
part of great for beginners we just got
it and don't know if they'll complete
overall I think is cute isn't bad what
if you think you're gonna continue
giving it is taller than best if you
spend just a few bucks and buy cheap
cheap with the number of cheap cubic
feet there are these days such as a gwan
long why I shouldn't be a problem
because cubes are to the guam on only
cost four dollars for just four bucks we
had so much more than whiskey
nevertheless if you don't want to spend
money and have our books you've just
lying around this is a great option it
isn't too fast that you still just a
perfect cube for time for 30 please also
can improve thank you so much I don't
recommend this for anyone classes in 30
seconds after all around playa then go
right ahead you shot the heart I don't
for beginners its strength but it
already have a better camp personally
I'll be sticking to my along me too
surprise surprise a revolutionary too
but I serve its purpose also if you're
already happy with your cube well
currently have there's no reason to
Stratus tell me in the comments if any
of y'all are gonna tribal but before I
end this video i just wanna sing the
reason that there has been no cute
videos for customer is because possess
keep asking the same questions such as
show your face which i can't do also i
have a lot
over so I didn't have time to meet a
cute video sorry about that guys but
that's all i had to have to say to this
video so don't forget to like me on
facebook follow me on instagram and
twitter and of course subscribe now
thanks for watching guys but all joking
aside Jay Cooper I love your videos
they're very entertaining thanks for
making them please continue thank you